[Musique]
les 12 millions d'habitants de l'île de
france pourrait bientôt connaître les
mêmes week end à la maison que les
dunkerquois ou encore les me soit
l'urgence est de soulager les hôpitaux
je pense que le gouvernement a réalisé
que là on était au pied du mur et que si
on ne faisait rien on courait à la
catastrophe
le moment est venu parce que ça ne
commence pas du tout arrêt des cendres
on est plutôt dans une phase
d'accélération et le moment est venu
pour permettre à l'ensemble des
franciliens d'avoir accès aux soins et
de se soigner
j'ai le sentiment que je suis pas plus
chiante hi-fi que vous j'ai le sentiment
que plus on attend plus la potion sera
dur est-ce qu'il est mieux d'être deux
mois ferme et complètement versus six
mois sept - 8 - 9 points comme on est là
qu'est ce que vous en pensez à moi je
pense qu'il aurait fallu fermer en
descente janvier pendant l'hiver pendant
l'hiver c'est pas non plus la même chose
de fermé pendant l'hiver que maintenant
le mot fait peur oui c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on tourne autour du pot
comme je suis en train de le faire mais
je pense qu'il faut effectivement
réduire les contacts 7 jours sur 7 il a
été décidé ce matin en conseil de
défense que des mesures supplémentaires
seraient prises dans un certain nombre
de territoires dans les prochaines
heures
des concertations seront amenés par
l'état avec les élus locaux
on ne peut pas gérer ce pays à coût d'un
mélange de deux madame irma et de
pinocchio réunis comme le fait souvent
le le représentant du gouvernement donc
le gabriela taki qui lui donne de
l'espoir mais de faux espoirs et nous
savons bien que dans 48 heures même
avant même dès demain soir et bien 23
millions de français risque d'être dans
un confinement
le premier traumatisme y avait des
mécanismes de défense très efficace
notamment l'humour il y avait des gens
qui avaient un talent d'humour
extraordinaire pour le 2ème confinement
ya pas du tout d'humour on est usé c'est
à dire une sorte d' usure de larmes
coulent les gens le disent dans la vie
quotidienne on en a marre féministe avec
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
annoncera demain à 18 heures dans une
conférence de presse
les mesures qui seront retenus pour ces
territoires pour une application à
partir de ce week-end tu attends que par
courtoisie républicaine le président de
la république convient la présidente de
région le président des maires à une
concertation très large sur ce sujet et
je déplore que nous n'ayons pas été
invitée à son déplacement à poissy donc
simplement vous dire qu'on sera là et
qu'on continuera de prendre les
décisions comme on l'a fait depuis le
début qui sont les décisions
pragmatiques proportionnée
territorialisées voici donc à quoi
pourrait ressembler la nouvelle carte
des départements confiné en plus du
pas-de-calais de dunkerque et du
littoral niçois ici en rouge seraient
donc concernées l'ile-de-france les
hôtes france et les 8 départements
limitrophes
on sait qu'on a en tant que quelques
semaines pour que le johnson & johnson
arrive
c'est maintenant
à la fin de l'interruption brutale un
dess images finalement ce qui était la
fraîcheur en 2017 est de plus en plus
perçu comme de l'amateurisme c'est ça la
réalité
emmanuel macron était un amateur
l'ouverture du procès bygmalion à paris
un procès qui va décortiquer le
financement illégal de la campagne
présidentielle de 2012
ç'a valu une mise en examen nicolas
sarkozy 18 millions d'euros de factures
c'est très simple parce que c'est très
vrai oui c'est que nicolas sarkozy n'a
osé ses proches de n'ont aucun intérêt
dans cette entreprise directement
strictement sq
sans surprise le procès a été renvoyé un
des avocats s'offre du coc vide
à écouter nicolas sarkozy bat à l'église
a voté pour pour emmanuel macron j'ai
évité vous l'a dit paris en tout cas ça
sera sans moi
thomas pesquet va devenir le premier
commandant français de la station
spatiale internationale il doit à
s'envoler le 22 avril depuis la floride
et ce sera sa deuxième mission à bord de
l' iss